i would love for you to consider magic
mind
it is the alternative to procrastination
you tired of wasting your time don't do
it anymore
magic mind flow state now comes in a
bottle
test drive it magic mine dot co
promo code theo for 10 off today's guest
uh has had eight
number one uh musical hits in music
and he is um you know he's kind of that
soft-spoken
sheriff you know he's uh
you know but his his um the breadth of
his work
and his success is very loud uh he now
has
a uh a band that he's i think providing
the label for we're gonna find out a
little bit more about him
um honored to have him in here today uh
he was
uh he grew up out in the central east
of america um it is mr
kane
[Music]
you my brown
[Applause]
yeah i don't know it's just like the
power's more like in people's hands you
know i mean you know some of that i mean
i saw you know you you would put
yourself
out there but i said your early videos
and it's like damn this dude you know
it's brave of a guy just kind of like
like i was up last night watching a
couple of them and
you know you got just you're sitting in
there and the lighting's behind you know
what i'm saying it's like
it's putting yourself out there yeah it
was just me and my cell phone
yeah but it's kind of crazy to think
that um
but that that's that like it's
interesting how
you got to take that first step of like
it's almost like vulnerability kind of
you know to put yourself in that space
you know yeah i mean you got people
coming at you from every which way some
people like you some people don't like
you
it's just i don't know i guess it kind
of
you gotta it kind of made me figure out
how to take some of the
i don't know how to say it just just get
myself ready for the industry basically
oh you mean by putting yourself out
there like that yeah yeah cause when i
got here you know it was like there
i was by myself and now you know i have
all this power behind me
so yeah that's a good point because i
guess yeah with comments and stuff i
mean it gets harsh if you get down in
there
yeah i used to read everything oh yeah
dude do you have one there's some about
me that are so funny bro like
um like like uh theo looks like a guy
that sells drugs out of build-a-bear
you know just [ __ ] like that like things
that's just like uh do you ever have any
are there any that stood out in your
mind and you're like damn that that one
really
no a lot of them were just especially
when i was first getting into the scene
it was a lot of them
uh that i would just say like
i was you know this dude's a rapper it
was like all kind of all that stuff just
going off my appearance
oh yeah yeah just things like that yeah
um
yeah ms because you for i mean you're
you your rise has been like in the last
two or three
years right i mean like really blow i
mean like i knew you've but i mean to
really get to like a crazy level like
you're pretty famous now
yeah it started the the uh like the
patrick my home is a country music now
everybody says i look like i'm a dak
prescott oh really oh now jack i can see
i never
i just thought because you kind of buy
because you're mixed you know kind of i
would think that
of patrick mahomes but i didn't think of
dak you do look like dak i think
appreciate it
yeah right right yeah um
did uh but that is crazy going to a
level where it's like
now you're like you have to hide and be
faint it's like you got to play hide and
go seek like kind of constantly a little
bit
yeah well at first it's kind of cool now
at first it it started to get a little
crazy
and then now it's like you know that
when people stop trying to take pictures
with you that's when you need to worry
yeah you know so now right now it's just
you gotta you gotta look at the positive
and everything
yeah so it's pretty cool i'm you know
i'm excited to be where i'm at and
provide for my
family just you know having a good time
you uh
what have you been doing during the
pandemic like for fun like what have you
been doing like picked up any hobbies
dude you just been resting like what
have you been doing be honest with me
bro well no i mean
there's not really much to do um like
you've been hunting you've been shooting
anything you've been chasing you know i
went hunting like three times
um which in my in my property they come
up to my back
really yeah i could shoot them off my
porch which i feel bad so
yeah you can shoot them with a handgun
we actually we actually just started uh
building like a treehouse slash luxury
um dear blonde oh really so it's gonna
be
cheating but it's gonna be pretty cool
how luxury we talking like what's going
on i'm going
to floors and uh you know windows it'll
just open whenever
i don't know if i'm going to push a
button bro you got to use a rope
if you do push button in a deer blind
that's going to be cool
you might get some heat for it you know
we're doing a little two-story
oh yeah that'd be nice man um
what about sports you follow any
specific sports actually
yeah i mean football and basketball um
i've got into draftkings like crazy
really yeah during this year betting on
stuff yeah
i gotta go for the underdog man you do
yeah i just i just won some
serious money off the the mcgregor fight
yeah who'd you bet on
uh the other guy pourier yeah come on
man i mean
he's been on this show twice bro i mean
in my heart you know like i felt like
mcgregor was gonna win
and you know it's just mcgregor but i
was and my whole house was going for
mcgregor so i was the only one and
you know he came out pretty nervous yeah
and so i was laying in the floor and
then when he started getting those
couple licks in my baby was asleep
i just started freaking out i was
yelling and everything yeah
bro my wife was like shh and i was like
hell no not tonight honey
not tonight he was going against me too
she was like why would you put money on
him
and i was like you gotta go for the
underdog yeah that's crazy man
yeah i got to i was lucky enough to get
to go talk with dustin because he's from
louisiana that's where i'm from so
to go talk with him right before the
fight before he went over to um
abu dhabi or dubai i think it's the same
place honestly
but um yeah dude i was so ecstatic bro i
watched that corner pub
and i was swinging off the rafters i
literally hurt my neck i wasn't even in
the fight
and i hurt my neck but i had to get
injections last week man so anyway
a dude i was so amped uh but yeah i bet
on him man and did you see the guy
before him michael chandler he's from
here
or he lives here yeah yes uh what i
didn't know he was from nashville i
found out after the fight but i actually
ended up putting money on him because i
think he was the underdog
yeah he was bruh dude that's the same
bets i made man
that's dope do you watch a lot of ufc or
no i do and it's like the big card
fights
yeah um but not on a regular have you
seen that guy israel at a sonya
is that the dude that's like anderson
silva um
he's kind of you know what actually
maybe he is like the new anderson silva
he's a little more streamlined can you
get a picture of him up
he's a little more streamlined this dude
man you watch him it's like watching
the harry potter of freaking it's like
the dark harry potter brother
is oh he's next level right he's like a
video game bro
he fought silver oh yeah he fought silva
yeah
he beat silva but it was kind of like i
think it was more of a
just entertainment you know both of them
doing the crazy stuff
right right and yeah i think he ended up
knocking him out i might have gotten
into ufc after that i've only been
watching for let me see maybe about
three years
okay i'm a white belt too oh are you
yeah sick
i mean you get they give it to you when
you walk in but yeah but i
hadn't even walked in yet all right oh
so you a parking lot fighter yeah yeah
there we go
yeah that's where it changes from the
streets to the map man would you ever
would you ever do what you think bro
it's been for me to go it's been
fascinating man man i've been getting in
a boxing recently
um i've got a boy that uh actually
is a fighter right now he's trying to
work his way up i was thinking about
trying to
get my manager to manage him and you
know try and get behind him but
he's like seven and one uh he lost to
the the number one guy it was like his
second fight
but every other one's been a knockout
he's pretty good and does he fight it
like just regular spots like is it like
because i used to go watch boxers when i
was coming up a friend of mine just do
billy conforto and r.i.p
he died he drove into uh like the side
of a bridge or something he was on pills
but
he um he uh
he was like he was the first first of
all first gay prize fighter i ever knew
bro
toughest dude ever bro knocking people
out and then flirting with him while he
was unconscious you know i'm saying he
was a bad dog
and uh but his whole family was prized
fighters so we would go watch
uh and we would go watch and it would be
like in a
sometimes it would be like in a bar
something would be like in a conference
room at a holiday inn like
it was just the most unique spots where
the fights were you know it wasn't like
in
you know arenas and stuff yeah what's
your boy fighting in he does uh
i guess like like people pay to go watch
him and he's on pay-per-view and stuff
like that oh wow it's like the
the low bar but they're actually like
fighters like they have a ring
people come watch them right um it's not
like that backyard fighting
no no no that's tough i love watching
that so when it comes up on facebook
they always have the craziest names that
was like shogun versus biscuit magic you
know they always got the freaking
weirdos
on the wall and somebody always usually
gets knocked out pretty quick i feel
like
that's hilarious those fights remind me
of mortal kom
of almost the gay mortal kombat the way
they have it put it together yeah
we used to do something like that in
high school after uh after we get out of
high school everybody would go to uh
this guy named frady's house
and everybody would go over there and
box
did people get real with it or was it
just yeah yeah it was like you don't
want to fight him
damn but but it was all kids from your
high school so it's like you knew not
who not to mess with right you know you
used to go on the bathroom
and just randomly start fighting
we used to uh when i went to this school
in arizona for one semester i got kicked
out of where i was living in louisiana
and i went to arizona and it was all the
kids there was all my high school was
predominantly mexican man like full or
mostly latino i think it was mexican but
mostly latino but
they would go fight in the car wash
after school like for some reason the
car wash was like the place where people
would fight you know
in the car wash uh yeah in the car right
inside of it yeah
and the people like the cars would have
to stop they would get all pissed people
would be honking
and you just have two dudes just in
there throwing down because i think you
could come in from each side of it
so you knew when you won when the guy
came out the bat oh gotcha you know
like if you came out i
yeah like yeah yeah if you came out your
side then you lost yeah so it was kind
of like a mad max kind of
a little bit you know but
yeah i love growing up uh like in a
rural area did you grow up pretty in
like a pretty rural area
uh i grew up in photoshop georgia so i'm
gonna say yeah
i guess but like was it just kind of
like not a ton of people you know
yo yeah yeah for those probably 9 000
people but it's
but the thing about where i'm from is
it's it's like you got 4-0 and like
everyone's a rival so like i'm close to
chattanooga tennessee
oh yeah but even um like so all the
georgia schools around that area are
rivals georgia ringgold heritage
uh all the high schools you mean yeah oh
so there's a lot of beef out there yeah
yeah yeah
there's like news like heritage when i
was in high school was the new school
and so like everybody hated them yeah
and so their their option was to beat
everybody and everybody else's option
was to beat them like that was the main
focus
dude that kind of stuff was fun that's
one thing i do miss bro sometimes it's
just that high school
like just like the beef and the vibes
that there were in high school because
you had like a
you had like an enemy it wasn't a real
enemy but it was like you had like
somebody to like go against you know
yeah like we had like salmon growing up
was a high school
and um chris duhan played there he ended
up playing at duke and then went to
he played for the bulls for a long time
a couple teams but i remember like
um he would come to and play our school
and everybody would be so like against
him
and he would tell everybody to be quiet
in the stands and then shoot and just
hit it every time
yeah but i missed that high school
rivalry
i missed that all of that dude growing
up like in a rural area was pretty
uh it was fun dude people would have
parties sometimes
and so you would go one time went to
this party and these guys were like had
this
house that was off the road aways and so
you had to walk to get there
and you had to walk through this field
but they didn't tell anybody they'd put
a uh
electric fence in the middle of the
field right so you're walking it's night
time
and this before cell phones so people
we're just you know hoping for the best
you know what i'm saying bro you just
had the light of the lord you know what
i'm saying you just walking just get
those
we had some friends that would hold on
to them uh uh really
yeah i did it by accident one time
you did yeah it's like once you grab one
it was a cow fence
once you grab it have you ever held one
i've held on uh
i got electrocuted at a carnival on the
zipper rod one time pretty good
like for at least about 15 seconds bro
like i was on a carnival ride
yeah on the way out i touched like one
thing and like two hand like the
the rails basically what you're supposed
to touch when you're leaving bro but
apparently you're not supposed to touch
both of them right huh
and i just locked up yeah you can't you
can't let go it just holds on yeah
and the guy was like get off the ride
and i literally couldn't say anything
bro because i was getting electrocuted
you know and he kept yelling at me bruh
and then he called me a couple names
and literally i remember he put his foot
in my back and just kicked me off the
ride
thank god he did yeah my situation i
held on for about five seconds and i
couldn't let go and then
next thing i know it just it threw me
back damn really yeah it was wild
that should be uh uh i feel like that
should be a new game
there's a tick tock you need to go look
at it's pretty hilarious
it's this guy from another country or
something bro and he's
another country yeah he he holds he's
like this one guy that goes and touches
the fence and he's like oh dude that's
gnarly and he's like
this dude just you know he gets lit up
baby so he he yeah he does he like cries
or whatever so the other guy he's like
he's just a baby he's from so-and-so
like so he goes and touches the fence
and he's like whoa
and then afterwards he's like i'm gonna
do it again and he goes and he touches
it again he's like
yeah and he tells his friends like you
got to do this so then he goes back and
he just holds on to it he's like
that's crazy you see it uh sean
i wonder if that would be like a new
sport you know we had jess lockwood in
here
and he's a uh he's like one of the
number one bull riders in the world
right i mean this kid is
i think he's probably 23 not 24 maybe
i mean he looks like a baby you know his
body's kind of he's the perfect height
whereas like
his like where you bend is right in the
middle of his body so that's kind of
perfect for
bull riding because it's like you kind
of you know you just are like that the
whole time
but i wonder if pbr could do like a
sport where it was just like
electric fence riding you know like just
locking in and staying as long as you
could
oh yeah i wonder what sport will be next
man because they're always kind of
coming up with something new
you know i've been waiting for that
basketball
yeah so to do this the movie oh the one
uh i didn't see it what is it about
it's like i ain't seen it forever but it
was like a huge thing back in the day
basically i've heard of the term yeah uh
was it did it look like a good sport
i mean yeah i mean in the movie it was
professional so i mean they got you know
so what did you start with the ball at
home played and you got to run the first
base kind of thing
man it's been so long since i watched it
but that was i mean
it'd be a cool sport oh yeah oh i think
anything man i think mixing up anything
you know
i don't know what the next one will be
well you know they had um
xfl or arena football was trying to be
big right before kovan remember and it
just killed it off
is that no i think it was xfl what was
it shown was that xfl
i think that was xfl yeah i mean bottom
line they just ran out i remember they
were suspends operations is the league
finish
the xfl suspended operations and laid
off
yeah a grim outlook for the future
yeah this is right when kobe picked up
this is april 10th yeah
so because they had just started out do
you remember you even see any of it
oh yeah so i knew it yeah they were just
trying to get fans again they spent
all that money to build the hype and
everything and then uh
and then that was it man um we got a
question that came in from a viewer
right here man let's get into it here we
go
from damn luke combs maybe sent this
enter his son
yo what up theo what up kane this is
dallas from houston texas
question for kane how does it feel
to be a trailblazer in your industry
right uh not a whole lot of brothers in
the country music space
you know but i think you've done well
with it uh
similar question to you theo i know you
kind of talk about it all the time but
what's
like being you know a southern brother
a southern man southern gentleman in uh
hollywood you know similar plight uh
you know there's a lot of stereotypes on
both accounts let me know what you guys
think gang gang buzz buzz
game bro um well i'll answer first is
that okay yeah
yeah i don't fee i don't fee i just feel
like hollywood kind of forgot
i feel like sometimes this is just my
perception also i don't know if this is
anybody else's i just feel like
sometimes hollywood forgets
that there's a lot of talent
uh that everybody from the south isn't
like a racist person or isn't a bad
person or isn't narrow minded or isn't
dumb or isn't
or can't be creative i think that they
you know when i was growing up they just
had shows that there was a little bit
more i feel like diversity of
um of where people were from you know
and then i think they started to get it
just started to get a little bit
narrow um but i think that that
also provides a lot of opportunities for
people to start their own platforms
and also for cities like nashville who
still who have like a real confluence of
i feel like kind of everywhere there's a
good southern vibe here but there's a
lot of people from
all over here so for i feel like
you know um for me i feel like
i did feel like a lot of everybody
thought i was just a redneck you know
nobody gave me a chance to kind of get
to know me i feel like in comedy
um but i think it also kept a chip on my
shoulder that made me want to keep
trying harder
and also made me have to be creative and
made me have to kind of prove myself a
little bit
maybe if i'm real honest you know and if
i'm
you know it's some of that could have
been on my own head too like i think
they hate me that kind of [ __ ] that
eminem type of [ __ ] you know you're just
running around [ __ ] eating spaghetti
you know [ __ ] angry at everybody you
know like some of that could have been
also in my head but
sometimes you need something in your
head to keep you
going you know yeah um but i don't but
i don't i don't know if i feel i'm just
as a country music listener i don't know
if i feel like there's a lot of
like uh vitrol towards black or any type
of entertainer that's different in
country music but there may be you may
have a different
experience uh not for me man it was like
you know that when i first came in
that's what i was kind of nervous about
and you know i did get a couple of
racial slurs here and there
um but my fans is what accepted me and
they pushed me to where i'm at now
um so in my head i was just like you
know as long as
they're behind me um and i got country
radio behind me
it's like i quit thinking about anything
and you know i just kind of do me
and just have fun with it i know me yeah
yeah
i feel you man yeah and also look if a
black dude calls you any word it's
pretty cool i think that's cool you know
what i'm saying bro like i got called
like a week ago you know and i
honestly i was pretty excited but this
liquid death is really keeping my
my uh my my mind fresh
and my body fresh and washed out good
sipper speaking of fresh
this year we're all looking forward to a
fresh start and that is true
and the best fresh start you can have is
some self-care
you know you want to care about yourself
you're not a voodoo doll
you know you need to do better for you
and that's why they have fresh
scents from native
native native aluminum-free deodorant
don't put
aluminum under your arms what are you
doing boy
put it down what are you doing you got a
tin can under your arms what are you
doing
native aluminum free deodorant is a
great addition to your 2021 routine
native cares about what do you put in
your pits
their ingredients include things like
coconut oil and shea butter things
you've heard of
none of their products are tested on
animals and almost everything is vegan
that's right native will have you
walking around smelling like coconut and
vanilla
citrus and herbal musk or maybe
even lavender and rose
dang you definitely down to meet someone
diverse if you smell this good
you can choose from over 10 cents native
deodorant has over 16
000 5 star reviews and has been featured
in the today show
for a reason make the switch to native
today by going to
nativedeo.com
theo or use promo code theo at checkout
get 20 off your first order get 20 off
your first order
that's native deo.com theo or use
promo code theo at checkout for 20 off
your first order
um here's a here's a guy you've inspired
right here some fella right here sending
we we just got a ton of videos we put
out for people to send in questions
here's one from a fella shawn bigger
what is his name sean baker
what's up kane what's up theo i got
another one for you
you going almond brothers
are you going grateful dead
[Music]
let me know gang gang bro what you going
man what do you think
i don't know what he just played right
there i have to go with the alma
brothers
he had an own brother sound pretty good
play him again man let me hear it again
a little slide action what's up theo i
got
another one for you you going almond
brothers
are you going grateful dead
man i do almond brothers man they really
sometimes they give me especially if
it's in the summer man i've been out on
a boat or something and i'm wet and i'm
cold i'm waiting for somebody to bring
me a towel bro
the only thing that makes me feel okay
bro is here in the almond brothers
but i'm a huge john mayer fan so the
fact that he goes in with the grateful
dead and knows so much about them and
like two i mean like
and when he goes on tour with him he
does he plays like second fiddle like he
doesn't even try to be the star
you know he's just like the background
element and like
pretty powerful to see him do that so
but i think just growing up like that
song melissa that one always gets me
i love allman brothers man i'm gonna
i'll probably go home and brothers
thank you i'll do almond brothers as
well yeah
what um what uh
let me think about what i'm gonna ask
you next
what uh when when you were growing up do
you remember your first kiss when you
were growing up
uh my first kiss yeah um i was
in a trailer park yeah and i was like
seven years old and she was like 13.
damn really
yeah 13 bro and how did you even meet
her
she was a neighbor okay my nana
uh was the owner of the trailer park oh
really yeah
nice man so she uh
dang that's crazy bro so uh well
i remember my first kiss was they had
this girl named chrissy was her name
right and she we live in like a four
plex like four apartments and so
i don't know how bro her brother was
always flirting with me too honestly bro
i'm real honest bro
but um but she
she had like a little bit of like a she
had like an overbite and i had an
underbite so i'm thinking in my head
we're supposed to be together
you know what i'm saying right we got a
lip lock like we got to make the world
complete you know
because we each other's missing links
but um
and i remember oh i invited her over i
don't even know how i did this dude i
invited her over to see my pillow in my
room
bro like i was just trying to think of
anything
so i was like oh you got to come see my
pillow and so she came into my room and
then we like kissed really fast
and then her mom used to drive this like
kind of toothpaste colored corvette it
looked like crest blue
right like this thing was real sparkly
and the mom would sit in the car with
her sunglasses on when she was too drunk
and wouldn't even drive and just play
the radio and just like
do cigarettes out the window bro just
kind of chill and the mom made us kiss
again
in front of her which freaking blew my
mind bro i was like damn i guess we
going on tour
yeah my mind was like uh you know
everybody's first kiss just like oh yeah
that's all i wanted
and it was like i left i don't even
think i talked to her again
after that it was like okay that was
cool you know
so yeah a lot of his fear man some of
it's just so much of like
i think people have been trying to get
us to kiss each other all the time and
so it felt like this thing you know
but what was it like what was halloween
like in a trailer park was it pretty fun
at halloween over there
dude that was it was sick man it was
honestly probably the best time of my
life
um you know i got i got
caught smoking cigarettes my papa made
me eat the pack afterwards
how many did you eat bro be honest dude
no he made me literally chew
the whole pack no
dog that's illegal i don't think you'll
ever be the same after that oh dude i
went through some stuff as a child
uh and then like i remember and it's it
sucked at the moment but now
just looking back it was like it was
awesome i remember having to go and uh
pick my own like hickory switch
and i picked i picked like the smallest
one which hurt the worst honestly
and then i'd go back and she but this is
too small so she whipped me with it make
me go back but
the sad part was every time i went to go
get this
it was all it was in poison ivy every
time i went so i would get a whip in and
then i would come back i'd have poison
ivy afterwards
yeah it was a it was brutal but looking
back it was awesome yeah that's awesome
bro
dude my mom so my mom got the smallest
car bro i don't even know how right she
had four kids
and my mom raised us you know and so she
had four kids and so
the car was so small bro so it was not
good because mom could hit
everybody from the front seat right yeah
so it was like a ford festival it looked
like a little
and it was two-door i don't even know
how we all got in there but i felt like
the cops sometimes would pull us over
because it just looked like something
was wrong right because you had too many
people in the car like you were up
against the window
but my mom could beat everybody just
with her own arm dexterity from that
driver's seat like drums probably
playing symbols
like she would go off on us man and she
would uh
what else would my mom do dude that was
really
we didn't have anything like that so
your grandpa made you go get a switch
oh my my nana oh your grandmother yeah
she used to make me do that
damn that's gangster dog and then was
she really really cool is she still
alive
yeah she's still alive oh nice man yeah
she must be so proud huh
yeah she's uh so she's like i i don't
really see her anymore she's
on my brother's side so it's uh my i
have a half brother and it's his dad's
mom
okay you have halfway i think it's
actually his dad's
like his his dad married her
so she got married into the family i see
yeah so she wasn't even by blood
wow and she raised you or she was there
she helped raise me
uh my actual my nana kathy's the one
that raised me uh which is my mom's mom
okay so i mean i still see her a lot oh
yeah yeah she was supposed to come up
today
oh no my family tree is like so
confusing because i have so many pat
balls and mammals and nana's
and tops and granddaddies it's like my
wife's tried to keep up and she's like
i'm
lost and i bet they pop even more out of
the woodwork now i bet they got you got
side uncles you got everybody
cousins i'm finding out about yeah
that's wild man
um let's pull another question in here
sean here we got a young fella right
here he's got a question for us
yo what up theo gang ro what's up kane
uh my name is clay i'm a
singer-songwriter here oh run that back
real quick
look at the interaction he's excited to
talk he's like what up theo
gang bro he probably what's up kane um
[Laughter]
look man we'll edit it we'll edit him
for some reason oh no keep it in there
but he called for you bro he never sent
in a video before this guy i know he
hasn't what's up kane
uh my name is clay i'm a singer
songwriter here in nashville and um
kane i got a question for you if you
could name three other bands or artists
to go on a dream tour with who would
they be and uh
what order would y'all play in each
night yeah what y'all got
gang gang german shepherd
ruff ruff baby damn he put you yeah bruh
that's tough because he also said what
order y'all gonna play in yeah i don't i
don't know
it's that's one of the things we've
always talked about is like
you know me and me and al dean want to
go in you know together and tour again
voice tour bro people get stuck in the
mud just in y'all's voices bro well that
was that was my favorite tour
tour with him twice and he like i wanted
to go back out with him
but now it's like he's got you know
triple my number ones um but
if we play like a 12 000 seat venue it's
like we can both sell that out
right so it's how do you do it yeah you
know what i mean i mean obviously
i mean i look at it as al dean would
have to be the headliner
um it'd be a wild tour
yeah and some of it gets is it hard with
ego does ego come in it doesn't sound
like it when you're talking about that
because you guys
it sounds like you're willing to kind of
figure it out agents kind of get into it
sometimes
you know yeah i don't i don't have a big
ego so i just want to go out and have
fun
um the agent is a big thing
but i don't know i mean like i feel like
if i went out with jason
we would have to end up doing stadiums
yeah and then we would have to get
another big artist as well to come out
and you know
be with us well you almost answered this
dude's question bro who's that third you
know if you pick boosie badass dawg i'm
freaking in it bro
nah i don't know man um would you keep
it [ __ ] you you
you probably keep it country huh yeah at
that point yeah you'd have to i mean i
you know i got a couple pop songs and
it's cool dipping my toes in the water
every now and then and it's
um but i feel like if you know if if i
had to pick somebody
like my guy khalid you know i would love
to bring him in but yeah i saw him in
that new video you guys did with sway
lee that's dope
yeah he's from mississippi uh him and um
race trimmer it is yeah yeah them boys
damn they're so good
yeah he's a good guy man but it's like
five man he's a whole
five bro yeah he gets more vibey every
time you see him in a video he has like
a
like he has so many tattoos it's just
like he's just darker now like he don't
even know
yeah you can't even it's just everything
is just he just keeps evolving he's like
little wayne
like by the end like little wayne looks
like a christmas tree now when you look
at him like he got so much swag on him
you know
yeah no sway's awesome too man but uh
khalid dude he's just got
he's just so chill and laid back i
remember we were doing that music video
be like that and
he he don't move out of a foot box
but like whenever he's his moves that
he's doing he did this one thing i was
so jealous of because
he says don't cry in the song and he was
just vibing he just did this
oh damn and i was like how did you make
that look so cool bro
and so that's like every time i see him
now i'm just like
yeah some people just have coolness in
them bro
you know some people just have swagger i
think that's one thing going back to
conor mcgregor there's just something
about it
yeah you got that walk he's got that
yeah he's got the walk and he just it's
like a confidence at another level
you know yeah i always felt that way
growing up around even mostly like black
guys like our neighborhood was black and
white but the black guys
always i don't know they just had a
different level
of comfort with what they did like i
always felt like my like if i'm
making a move i'm thinking about it
first you know but the black guys always
just seemed like just
it was like they were just like living
in a river you know it just seemed like
and i'm out here i'm [ __ ] just kind
of hanging on the bank you know yeah
i think i was always envious of like i
think it's one of the reasons why a lot
of people getting me so black culture is
this
you know a lot of black guys seem so
confident you know but i saw that video
i saw that video actually and uh
i thought it was awesome yeah it's
definitely a little bit different oh
it's way different so who's that third
man you got to finish this off baby
who's that third so at least
you said already that jason aldean could
go
last very kind of you yeah and uh
and so yeah who would be that third on
there
man honestly
i would love to do i mean i would love
to tour with anybody really
but i feel like just with quarantine
my my three uh me included would be like
me
jason and john party oh yeah yeah just
because me and john's got really close
he's like my neighbor
is he really his wife supposed to cut my
hair actually really yeah yeah
yeah yeah i saw him at kid rock's
birthday party anyway
if you need another if you need a barber
just let me know dude i don't know if i
want that fade bruh
okay no don't get it you don't have to
get the fade but you could fade this
right here yeah i could do this better
yeah fade this well i'm not saying you
can do it better but i'm saying if you
faded this and then left the rest of
this
yeah maybe i'll do that man it's nice
yeah i would go for something man i've
been doing i've been seeing this little
lady over here that cuts it and she's
good but i i'll probably venture out
but yeah john said his wife was there
too and she's really
i said you better be there when she cuts
it john you know what i'm saying because
i don't want to get accused she's
actually waiting for my barber to come
back in town
oh really yeah he got his hair cut by
him in gatlinburg well then that's
strange because his wife cuts hair so
why are you telling me to go to your
wife john
if you see another barber dog if you
ain't even getting your hair cut in your
own house
that's ice cold man well he still gets
his haircut but they've been they've
been asking when c2 was coming back
yeah he's a good he's good oh he's
amazing what's his name
ct my friend sct
let's uh let's hear this guy right here
has a question so that's it john party
so that's the three man i'd be a good
tour and it'd be fun
that would be fun bro stay do you think
like
like you're at a level man you go to a
room you can do
yeah doing those level of ticket it does
get spookier once you get bigger it's
like
you know you gotta package it up it has
to make sense to the
the agents when it all makes sense or
otherwise you're taking a pay cut you
know
um well see the agents just care about
tickets so like
the thing for the artists is especially
when you've been doing it for years like
at first i didn't care who i was out
with i was excited
um which i was out with ftl so it was a
good tour to be on for the first tour
but
when you're an artist you also want
you're also with these people
all the time so you want it to be a good
hang you don't want to be the people
that just go on the bus and they don't
talk to you or
that's a boring tour yeah so but for me
it's hard to
go out with somebody that i enjoy their
company and hanging out with but also
fits my lane
of music as well right so
yeah that's a good point yeah yeah i got
invited in a movie last year
um and i went there and no it just the
hang was not good was gonna be 12 weeks
so luckily i was able to get out of it
but uh
man i was like dude there's just no hang
it's just like
going back to my hotel it just i would
have gotten into such like a
like a like a downward space you know
yeah
and comedian you just well at least you
get to bring like your opener and
somebody like that you know
um but i just do theaters but i think
i'm
i don't know if i'd ever want to do diff
anything bigger i don't know if
if you know if god would ever even have
me doing that you know if i don't know
if that's in my future but
i like theaters because it's at least
still for comedians it's still kind of
personal enough
because you're just talking you know
yeah whereas music i mean you get
everybody rocking i don't know if it
matters if they're in a small space or a
big space does it feel different to you
oh yeah um you know for a while i was
excited to just
you know be playing but once i put my
foot in the arena
it was like well because you hear like
just this different type of roar
with echo as well and then that's crazy
bro
you also you only see people in the pit
so it's kind of like you're still
playing
in you know just a regular bar but then
after that first couple rows it's black
yeah so it's like you can just have
the time of your life on stage you ain't
got to make eye contact with anybody you
can just kind of be yourself and
and when you just when you hear the roar
it just amps you up even more and it's
fun
damn that's interesting take cause i i i
never thought about it like that like
i'll play like
i think i maybe played 2500 in melbourne
in australia i think that was maybe like
the biggest amount that i did last
time but i could only see the front but
i always think like [ __ ] i'm scared
because i
i don't know where i'm supposed to be
looking for these people in the distance
you know and sometimes i won't even come
out early so i don't even know how big
the room is so i'll be like
yelling like it's a big room and then
the lights will come on at the end it's
like
they just got them kind of packed in i'm
like damn i just read the room wrong
but maybe that's a better take to just
perform for the people in the front you
know
yeah i mean if they're laughing
everybody else will be laughing yeah it
takes one person to laugh to make
everybody
else laugh yeah that's a good point bro
i know yeah
i never thought i just i always feel
like i'm just like kind of yelling into
this abyss
maybe because i think i'm focusing on
the abyss instead of focusing just on
the people in the front
yeah do you uh have you ever been to a
comedy show or no
i haven't i was trying to go to kevin
hart but he sold out for the next
eight years yeah so yeah it's you know
uh but have you have you ever heard of
benadon
he's a guy on instagram he's a he's a
comedian y'all should link up
can you pull him up man ben de don yeah
he's so he's uh he lives with odell he's
good friends with him
he's kind of in this la comedy group
he's also uh like
starting to put music out is he yeah
been to dawn oh i'm off to check him out
he's based out of la yeah man maybe i'll
have one a podcast next time i'm out
there
what's he like he's real funny dude he
just he don't care
really i mean yeah he don't care huh he
does not care
at all and you know him yeah he'll come
out on the road with me every now and
then hey you got to watch us do cat
williams it was before his time cap
williams
he's a little before him like decat
williams yeah yeah you know what i'm
talking about yeah
yeah he reminds me of him a little bit
some of those little moves that he does
and stuff he reminds me of catwoman a
little bit
because you got to think these guys
didn't have instagram they didn't have
any of that
so the only way to go see him was just
you had to go to the club to see him you
know
yeah he used to be like a different vibe
i feel like
yeah i love his skit about uh shaq
i don't even know if i've seen you yes
he said he went to shaq's kids birthday
party and he was like
he was like seven years old he said this
he said this baby came out and was like
or he looked at the baby and was like
[Laughter]
the baby was huge yeah hilarious saying
pick me up
so you pick me up
yeah kathleen is the best man i forget
about him sometimes
let's watch it uh type in uh shaq's
kid's birthday
that must be a thing friends with shaq
i'm going to talk about my friends now
[ __ ] it he's only like you with a mullet
too bro praise god
stupid [ __ ] this [ __ ]
got enough money to be whatever the [ __ ]
he want to be his whole life and what
the [ __ ] does this [ __ ] want to be
a goddamn sheriff you gave me no goddamn
sheriff shot
you are 18 foot 6 foot 12 [ __ ]
you can't even go undercover just do
your other drugs no shack
you know that's your [ __ ] ass
you a dumb [ __ ] if you let shaq
pull you out the car you
could you step out the car [ __ ] could
you make a free throw
then i'm not getting out there i'm just
not going to do it
[Applause]
you want that [ __ ] not to shoot you you
got to dress up like a basket
you can't shoot them he can't shoot
baskets he can't do it
that's my [ __ ] i can talk about it
i ain't scared of shack shack ain't even
a gangster and his family his wife is
the gangster she's my size she
had five of this [ __ ] gargantuan
dinosaur ass babies
she'll even give a [ __ ] no more jax baby
be three and a half years old when they
come out she be steady in the
conversation anyway girl i was going oh
[Applause]
man
your goddamn hands down everybody
picking you up they'll be the same size
dude you should go see him have you ever
had a comedian open up for you or no
there's a guy jim brew who's coming on
later this week um
he opened up for metallica for like two
years
that's it which i can't even imagine
it's pretty crazy it's hard in comedy to
go before
and do uh you seen this guy jim brewer
just hit a picture of him yeah it's hard
to go um
and and do before music
i bet especially the age differences
yeah because i got so many kids
and then they go you know all the way up
to 60 so oh wait your shows
yeah oh yeah so like i couldn't imagine
like you know yeah you can't even
yeah you couldn't even do it for you
then because it would have to be you
yeah you need like a specifically
zoned a age zone audience yeah
damn you don't even think about that
damn you got children at your shows
oh yeah dang that's crazy bruh
i usually my ritual is trying to bring
like one or two up on stage
yeah yeah some of them sing singing and
stuff yeah yeah so i'm saying some dance
some of them get shot when they get out
there mom just throws them up on the
stage
who does like their mom does there's
somebody oh that's crazy and so you just
pick them out like how does that work
out yeah like if you're picking somebody
out of the audience
do you tell a guy do you rate it like
how do you do it
uh sometimes if they're close enough
i'll just pick them up but sometimes the
rails like five feet back so nobody
can climb on stage so i usually get my
security guard to go grab them and bring
them up
dang yeah that's what's up that's a cool
moment
yeah oh i bet dude if i'm a kid man
i don't know if i'm i think if i'm so
young i would have no idea what's going
on
yeah but if i'm like 11 i think i would
be
i'd be nervous i was 11. yeah well they
get up there and
most of them's front row so they don't
see anybody behind them they're just
literally looking at the stage so when
they do get up there they're like
you know that's when they kind of just
you know
shy up real quick but oh yeah it's
always fun though especially when they
break out
i had this girl in there uh i think she
was like 12 or 13. she started breaking
down just started dancing
started killing it she did yeah oh
that's dope and the place goes nuts i
bet
you know there's something about when
things happen that are just impromptu
it creates like this different vibe in
people where they they can feel that
it's just like
absolutely real you know yeah like even
outside of music or comedy or anything
like
there's a moment to the show that people
love but when something happens it's
like it's crazy how the
the cheers then go to another level yeah
there's just something people love about
things being like live
yeah our show's super real man like you
know all these people
a lot of times they'll script or um
you know do things like practice
rehearsal and all that
it's like as long as i know my lyrics
and as long as i know what i'm
about like supposed to come in and what
i'm supposed to do i just
do my thing you know what i mean y'all
got animals or anything like that on
on it y'all do anything is that wow
that's surprising you know i
bought a champ bring it out dude get
something get you something man you uh
get bieber didn't beaver have a chimp
for jb have a chimp for a little bit
yeah i think he did
i don't know if i'm at that level at all
i could see you guys do something
together man well
bieber yeah yeah uh we gotta call him jb
i think
jb yeah sorry it's okay i mean i don't i
mean
i just noticed i've i've hung out with
him a couple times and i just noticed
other people say it
yeah so then i like okay because i i'll
call him beaver then i'm like [ __ ]
i'm thinking i'm like he's a child you
know then i get all freaking
self-conscious
but uh here's a question right here we
got from a young fella right here this
guy's somewhere in a sauna
what's going on theo what's going on
kane i'm laying in bed with my smoking
hot wife
smoking hot all right hey question for
you
uh what are your hobbies like what's on
your bucket list
have a good one gang yeah cause you
could do anything now i mean you got
enough money now you could own a
galapagos turtle you could buy your own
hawaii [ __ ] you could build a hawaiian
damn clarksville if you want to tell me
you could do whatever you want now
yeah man i'm very
i'm a very like homebody type of person
so like
you know a lot of people are buying
beach houses and all this i'm i'm
putting all my money into my
one house that i have um
you know just in you know kind of
investing in myself like that so
the money will always be there my house
value just goes up yeah um
and now as i'm getting older and
especially this year i don't know if
you've been on the stock game since the
game stuff and everything like that
i tried to get in some it's making me
reconsider everything you know and
trying
you know invest and put my money
elsewhere and
then when if i ever become a 800
millionaire
you know then then i might just start
splurging and doing whatever
dang you gonna wait till then bro
probably get you a bass boat at least
though huh you got a boat
i'm a i'm a cheapskate i borrow people's
boats i love that or i'll go out with
you know somebody else yeah you know
what the best about going out with
somebody vote when you get back to the
dock you just go home
they're over there empty and [ __ ] like
you know like throwing away coke empty
coke cans bro
i'm done um yeah so what's some things
what
what's that guy asking there hobby-wise
i know you game right you do some gaming
yeah game i'm trying to get out of it
um you do crypto you in crypto right now
dude i was
oh are you are you on the dogecoin oh
dude people's nosing out right now bro
i'm about to doze off bro i don't know
if doge is really gonna pop i think it's
a lot it's a lot of hype
did it did one night uh i went in at
um a penny
and uh almost two cents and that night
it
jumped to nine cents and i skyrocketed
did you sell or not oh immediately i
said it was like it's not gonna it's not
gonna
hit ten it's not gonna go up any higher
so that was good i don't think i think
it's off the
off the wall now though i don't think
it's gonna do anything yeah i think
songs you gotta get in like
now it's all getting too much you know
like the amc the gamestop
it's all just everybody knows about it
now naked juices all of this [ __ ]
dude i met a guy this is crazy i met a
guy on twitter
three two years ago he convinced me to
give him my ameritrade passwords right
so that dude now just does my stocks
probably like this dude right so
i've never met this dude right and uh
and he's a great guy
so if he listens but um
anyway he hits me up the other night
it's like five a.m
i gotta wake up to pee and i check my
phone and i shouldn't bruh but i do bro
it's the worst thing i ever do
so i check my phone and he messages like
hey hit me up call me
we've never spoken on the phone right
yeah so
i'll give you my ameritrade password but
i ain't taking a [ __ ] verbal call dog
you know what i'm saying bro
so anyway this dude
uh he's like so we start messaging he's
like buy these stocks
so we buy them we're up 20 two hours
later up 21 000 right so i'm freaking
geek dog we living high i'm buying [ __ ]
in my head i'm on instacart i'm [ __ ]
buying steaks you know what i'm saying
bruh
i got the two hour delivery i'm paying
extra i'm living life
uh the problem was right when we started
to sell
the ameritrade closed it down closed the
apps down by the time we sold
i had lost a thousand dollars so not
only did i not make the 20
21 that was all gone i lost a thousand
then i tried to get back in the other
day and i lost another two thousand
that's something that sucks i was trying
to sell today and it wouldn't let me
hopefully hopefully it's a good thing
though yeah yeah sometimes
yeah i guess sometimes there's a way to
look at it like that like oh maybe this
is what's best you know yeah
so you we do a lot for single moms on
this show right so it's just something
we've done over the years and you were
raised by your mom right yep
cool so we wanted to just surprise a mom
today and just call her
we're making an initiative this year to
donate twenty thousand dollars a single
mom just hitting them up
and um just giving them 500 on the spot
it's not a big thing but
dude if my if somebody would have called
my mom and gave her 500 bucks dog that's
huge
to see my mom get like a new dress or
just be able to get her hair done do
something for herself
that's a that's a car payment plus more
yeah depending on what car you got
yeah we had a dodge oh dude i remember
my mom finally got a dodge neon bro
and we thought we was living large dude
the first three nights we had it me and
my brother
slept in it bro that's how excited we
were bro yeah
we stayed out there and slept in that
[ __ ] dude mom's like you sure you want
to stay in it and we're like yeah wow
this thing is nice bruh pull up a
picture of that dodge neon dude gray
bruh gray
what kind of what what whip did y'all
have growing up
we had a gold spirit damn
and it was uh is that from the church i
didn't even heard of that car
no it was i don't think they made it
that was my car with those
circle freaking uh with those circle
front lights that [ __ ] was just
lights man that [ __ ] was snazzy let's
see that gold spirit though
pictures of the church coming up damn
y'all had that
one that was older yeah it's probably
like a
94 or something
was it like a cutlass kind of car there
it is there we go
boy let's go and so the back window is
like a little rectangle
i remember it got smashed one time
and we so we kept it together with duct
tape yeah
and i was i was young and i just i just
kept
looking at this smashed window and my
mom went in the grocery store one day
and i just like
i had this book in my hand and i
remember i just like slowly kept hitting
it harder and harder
and eventually it just all crumbled into
pieces and went in the back seat
and my mom was so mad she was like who
broke my window and i was like
maybe somebody was trying to break in i
was like i wasn't here you know
so i don't know i remember we had it uh
the top of it was falling down oh yeah
we had text yeah
yeah my dad's car was like that but he
wouldn't do the tax man my dad was
old my dad was 70 when i was born right
so he was an old man so by the time i
got to know him like when i'm seven or
eight years old he's
77 78. so he would drive but his [ __ ]
was falling in bro but he never thought
to get the tack so he was literally just
just pushing just pushing it up out of
his eyes and the windows down so the air
picked up
man and he couldn't even turn his neck
he had bad arthritis
so he would ask me bro i'm [ __ ] seven
dawg
i'm on sitting there on the seat
sometimes on my knees someone standing
on the seat you know just being a kid
he would be like can i go you know and
i'm [ __ ] like yeah you know like
i'm not even looking anymore just
sending him out man
damn yeah the end of that car man we
were at the
koa campground yeah and uh
we were in the pool and my pop drove it
and um
this lady comes out and she's like hey
your car smoking oh
and it was like such a piece of junk he
was like it does it all the time
he does it all the time and then five
minutes later it's completely inflamed
yeah
bro we had to get the call to fire the
fire trucks and everything
damn that's crazy that was the end of it
that's hey man it went up in flames bro
it's pretty epic really it's a good way
to go
yeah it's almost like in those old roman
shows when people just dot like they
like uh
like they'll fire an arrow they push
them out into the lake and they fire the
arrow and just like send it up in flames
you know
it's better than being buried you know
i'd rather be created probably i think
if i'm a car
um okay so let's surprise let's go we're
gonna who are we gonna call right now
nominated by your sister jennifer you've
got a ten-year-old daughter named
madison
okay oh i got a niche named madison yeah
before we do that actually i want to i
know you have a new band you see
you managing the group now or what's
going on yeah man so
it's kind of a cool story for us
especially if they break
um which i'm going to do everything i
can too or i'm not going to sign anybody
else but
um so this is it people you hear that
this is it yeah
so uh we i was when i was on x factor um
i went solo and they tried to put me in
a boy a boy group
and i said no and then ended up going to
do my thing now
um so and is that boy group still a
group
so yeah i signed them no way so this was
the boycott you're supposed to be in
yeah so they ended up coming in fourth
on the show
uh and ended up signing them
um and now they're here but what's even
crazier is they knew my wife
before i knew my wife because after the
show
they ended up getting signed by her
manager because she used to be an artist
as well
okay so they ended up getting signed by
her manager and then they all met and
then i met my wife and then i told her i
signed restless road and she's like what
you know restless road so it's just like
a full
circle moment you know it and i know it
and it is winter time
man it's winter god oh god
it's winter we're in the thicker winter
if you look on the calendar boy
you can't even these pages is stay
that's winter time man if you this is
the coldest part of a calendar if you
touch it touch a calendar you get your
face i bet
i bet you chilled up and i want to tell
you about
manscape is here to provide the best
tools to take care of your body you want
to head into the spring with that sleek
body
you know just like a comfortable stool
flying out of a
dolphin's ass baby you want to be sleek
look we've all groomed ourselves and you
can continue to do so with the lawnmower
3.0 trimmer
best hygiene tool for the modern man
manscape's performance package
best of 2021. look the bottom line is
that manscaped wants to take care of
your body because you can't
get 20 off and free shipping by going to
manscape.com
theo that's right 20 off with free
shipping
by going to manscape.com that's
manscaped
thank you for making our bodies
do good with hair
hello brittany hello
hey hey is this britney yes
hey my name is theo um i'm just calling
uh uh
uh your sister nominated you um
i just wanted to call and chat with you
about something can i call you on
facetime for a second
sure it's nothing perverse or nothing
like that
okay yeah everybody it's fully clothed
yeah so i'm gonna call you back on
facetime and just put your phone
sideways too
okay okay cool
let's make it a thousand bucks huh
hey can you hear me or not yes
okay cool um so yeah so we just i i i
work as a podcaster so we just do a show
and
um i was raised by a single mom and i'm
sitting here today with kane brown he's
a musician
and um he he was raised by a single mom
and his grandmother
and um or his nana sorry and uh is that
right
mama and then mom and nana so anyway we
know that you're a single mom and we
just try to do something all the time to
do something sweet
so we just wanted to send you a thousand
dollars to do something fun for your
daughter
madison so it's we're not trying to be
weird or anything we just thought it
would be
just something nice to do nope
i'm not kidding this cane kidding i'm
not kidding i'll tell you what i'll go
ahead and add another thousand dollars
how about that
dang cain is rich caden is rich honestly
so now you got two thousand two thousand
so what does your daughter like to do
i'm speechless well that was sweden kane
i didn't know he's gonna do that thank
you bro yeah man that's nice of you
my daughter is she's ten
she
she's got a good little mixture of
tomboy and girly
features that's just like kane
okay okay
um well what's something fun you guys
would go do what's something fun that
she likes to do
um i i own a jeep so we drive around in
our jeep
quite a bit yeah you go go off-roading
every once in a while but
just driving around in the jeep is
something that we do
together she loves shopping
she loves um
she loves everything she's just such a
great kid oh that's sweet we've recently
wanted to go on vacation but
unable to uh copen really
well you could go to florida with two
thousand dollars you could go to florida
it's open
you know that's crazy
i i don't even know what to say
thank you oh you're welcome yeah we
didn't mean to put you on blast either
we just
we were just talking about it like i
remember my mom growing up like
if somebody would just come out the blue
and just done something just to
offer just a little you know just
something nice where she could go do
something fun
and man it would have been man it would
have just made me feel good as a kid to
see that somebody cared about my mom
and it would have just been a little bit
easier on my mom mm-hmm
so um
he's so grateful well look you can put a
lot of gas in that jeep with 2g
so there you go well look we don't want
to mess you up on your lunch break or
anything but
um yeah we just wanted to say thanks for
being a hard-working single mom and your
sister nominated you is that right
yeah i think your sister nominated you
because she listens to to this podcast
and um yeah we just been trying to be a
part of single moms lives for a while
and so we're just
nice to meet you and i look forward to
meet you in person when i come in in
town to do a show
wonderful thank you so much okay you bet
be good bye
bye oh well that's
a sweet lady huh oh yeah um
thank you brothers nice of you yeah man
damn i didn't know he's gonna come over
here and have to spend a g bruh but
there you go that's cool
that's awesome man that's good um
so uh so we'll also we'll have to get
our tickets to restless road then bro
definitely well they'll be on tour with
me so they will yeah so we'll just have
to
send her send her some tickets dang bro
so you uh so was it crazy did they reach
out to you when you decided to sign him
or how did that kind of go down
no so uh zach and garrett were kind of
doing their own thing and colton
um kind of split off
so colton covered one of my songs and we
were talking about getting a label and i
was like
i think i'm going to go colton because i
had a you know a pass with him or
whatever and he was the one i was
closest with
in the band at the time um so he decided
he wanted to get back in with restless
road
so we had a meeting they brought
everybody in they started showing me
their music
um and they're just they're just so
different man they have like these crazy
harmonies
they can all sing none of them sound
alike
and it's just something different to
bring to country music
i like that man well that goes back even
to our first question man it's just
about
being different and doing different
things in the space man you know
and it's interesting when you come from
a place that's even just a little bit
different whether it's you
part of your history or uh you know
where your parents are from or where
you're from you know like
it's being a little different always
kind of sticks with you i think you know
and so it's interesting to see that it's
kind of transposing itself into um
into you recognizing difference you know
in what could be
unique for for the genre you know yeah
um
let's check let's check in with these
cats bro they're super funny man are
they yeah super witty
so it's colton garrett colton garrett
and zach
so zach's on far left he's got a deep
voice
garrett's uh medium
and then colton's like super west
virginia boy
okay medium garrett huh you got medium
garrett
dang this is what did i just pray
what did i just walk away sorry
look we were just saying he was just
describing y'all's body types you know
what i'm saying
i think it took a wild turn all of a
sudden
wait so he said i'm medium rare right
yeah yeah garrett's medium and then what
was i just the west virginia boys i was
trying to like explain y'all's voices
like because you're
like i said zach was low like he's got a
low voice
and then y'all y'all both are like
completely different as well but i
didn't know how to
say it oh okay that's all i was like i
was like you know
you got the you're like super west
virginia accent when you sing
yeah and then but garrett was at you
know kingsley's birthday party and was
singing that rock song
but he can also sing you know country so
i was just like he's medium
i was just putting you in the middle
medium garrett but i'm going to ask this
and so say you guys are trapped in a
it's like a
windstorm right y'all trapped bruh
something happened right
the trailer fell over brother the bus
driver was drunk dude he's been doing
percocets he's been doing pills he's got
issues with his second wife
so you guys are in a windstorm one of
y'all has to yell for help bro
upwind who's it going to be bro who do
you send it
right
there you go boy there you go that
triple a bad
boy with that triple a throat bro that
roadside assistance
so you guys have you guys gotten a tour
um have you guys gotten a tour with kane
yet have you guys gone out together yet
they got they got to put their toes in
the water yeah we
we actually went out i think it was
three weekends we did we did a total of
five shows
so it was like you know it was really
really fun and cool
and we got like j just just in there and
then coveted hit so
it was it was great while it lasted
though we will say that yeah
so you guys are praying this vaccine or
whatever happens happens fast huh
oh yeah yeah you know it's one of those
things like i think honestly it kind of
made us like feel
like even even more wanting to get back
out there like this time that we've had
to kind of
settle back in and like get creative i
think it's made us like more hungry to
like get back
on the road i think it could be looked
at as maybe a good thing
and so you guys met on the tv show i
didn't even know that you guys that you
were on this tv show so you met on the
game show uh the contest the music
contest right x factor
the price is right yeah so and sorry bro
i didn't
i did not do my homework some of it i
just you know um
but did were you guys bummed out when he
didn't want to do the uh
band uh well
we actually didn't know that you know we
got put in the group and
and kane wasn't in it and we actually
didn't know that he was meant to be in
it until later on and we all
actually reconnected and he kind of told
us like yo i was actually gonna be a
part of it and decided not to do it i
was like well
he worked out time at the time and he
was like at the top of the charts and we
were like well damn man
you chose probably the right thing to do
and now it worked out great that's
amazing how things work out sometimes um
yeah it's crazy man and i was just
thinking about this you know we were
just
like you know all in kane's truck the
other day listening to this uh this new
song we uh we just put out and uh
it was just really cool i was just like
i can't believe eight years later like
here we all
are all together working on this music
together and we all get to be a part of
it it's really
really cool and we keep saying you know
our catchphrase is how full circle
this all is and it really is and it's
really cool to get to work with kane
amen bro you know it's interesting how
if you
yeah it's so hard to realize at the
moment that that the
that there's a bigger picture going on
that you can't see
it's so hard to realize that like so
many things feel like defeats in our
lives or it feels like man it's supposed
to happen right now
yeah and then it doesn't happen for
eight years for 10 years for 12 years
and that's when it's really supposed to
happen it's just so hard to recognize
that man
you just gotta follow your good yeah
yeah yeah you just gotta follow yeah but
some of your gut is like
greedy bro my god gets greedy bro you
know my gut once that you know you want
it now
yeah and you want to be angry that it's
not happening but
you know to see you guys you know really
take this restless road honestly i mean
you know not to freaking
you know sound like as cliche as anybody
ever could but
um so what is it like what does you guys
just sound different is it like kind of
like the beatles but stuck in the woods
like what is it like tell me what's
going on
i love that we're using that you know
what man
i think one thing that's cool about our
group is you know we're really focused
on
harmonies but also we each like kane was
saying have these different voices
and uh we try to feature everyone's
voice in in each song
and i don't i don't really think there's
a lot of bands that that do that and
showcase different vocalists and
we each have a different style and we
each have a different story and a
background so it's really cool when all
those things come together
uh in the songs that we write yeah i'm
trying to think if there's a lot of like
uh
truettes or something what's a 3-3 duet
is it a true
trio a trio yeah my bad i'm trying to
think of how a tree if they have a lot
of
i guess they've had like rascal flats
dixie chicks yeah but
even with like them yeah they don't they
don't all
sing yeah so like it's usually the one
and it's something that for years you
know ever since this band started that
people have always told us oh you can't
have more than
one lead singer and i mean we've got
told that for years and you know for a
while we believed it and it really
wasn't until we
started working with kane and we felt
like we got this whole clean slate this
do-over and we were like we're gonna
finally do this
the way we want to do it sing the songs
record them the way that we want to and
that's exactly what we've been doing
that's hype uh that's crazy and now all
y'all get to be lead singers that's
freaking wild
yeah we're all the justin
brothers ain't going to end well but i
love it
nobody wants to leave because you're all
doing your own solo projects while
you're doing the
the trio dude that's wild bro that's
dope dude this could be fun
yeah so does kane help you do you help
them put the music together do you are
like are you having a hand in that kind
of thing or you just
uh man they're super creative um so it's
it's cool that i mean i literally just
kind of sit back
and then whenever something's about to
get released we kind of
you know just all strategize on how to
release it together
um i mean my biggest thing is just kind
of using my platform and my fans and
social media to
to help them get bigger um i followed
you yesterday guys
oh man thanks dude yep yeah i will say
kane kane is being pretty modest on that
i think when we went and did our first
ep you actually were really hands on
like
in the studio with us and you actually
had some really great ideas to
you know with like musical arrangement
stuff and
and harmony parts and keynes cain's more
than just music advice i mean he's our
personal trainer he's our yeah
you know relationship today i showed up
too one time
hey that you that's more than you can
say about watching but it's watching you
that's continuing to motivate us
yeah watching yeah watching game work
out is y'all's a new thing i like that
that's classic i don't bite your lip
when he says zach
i think we're gonna on the way out today
we're gonna listen to some uh one of
y'all is it a new song so tell me what
do you guys
like i actually used to work as a tour
manager man i used to work
i was a tour manager for josh kelly so
charles kelly
his brother did music before him georgia
clay
yeah i remember georgia clay only one of
my friends with a fake id yeah
yeah that's awesome so i got hired as
his tour manager so we went to all the
radio stations around the country
and we're just trying to you know like
he was playing for him in the morning
and stuff like that
i mean we went to i mean i don't even we
went everywhere man and um
and josh and i are still friends i know
charles i think lives in nashville i
don't know but
um but anyway so yeah i remember he had
a single they were trying to push on the
radio and stuff like that
what are you guys like how do you guys
how are you introducing this band to the
world kind of
dude it's a lot harder now especially
during this pandemic because they
can't get out to these you know the
radio stations so
we're you know trying to look towards
the fans because
like i feel like labels and they do too
is everybody's going they're telling
them like you got to blow up on tick
tock for us to put this song out
which is [ __ ] yeah um so we're just
trying to get through
to the fans and everybody and just let
them hear the music i mean they sound
the exact same as they do
live as they do on uh the song so it's
just i know they have they're super
talented and i'm excited for them and
uh when we get back on the road they're
i feel like they're gonna take off
that's awesome bro
dang dog y'all get to go on a freaking
big tour dog
it's gonna be dude i cannot wait i'm a
lucky bruh
dang bro y'all lucky bro
really we definitely feel that way for
sure yeah dude
we always we can't believe it honestly
it's been it's been a really
i mean we uh did that first show with
kane last year and like i'm not gonna
lie we all got off stage and got in the
green room and cried like babies
yeah i was just overwhelming because
it's just something that you think about
and visualize for so long and then
just to walk out there and and i mean an
arena
period is amazing but an arena filled
with fans like keynes is just i think a
whole different
thing and and we got to be a part of
that and it was just we we can't wait to
do it again hey man that's the oats man
yeah it's cool to see dreams kind of
come true you know just see them in this
moment like right now they're all kind
of like you know
comfortable and they're all chilling
fast forward two years you guys
one of y'all will have face tats one of
you guys will have
lost an arm everything there we go
everybody
look like little wayne like it's gonna
get way interesting bro
it's gonna get weird for sure one of us
is just gonna go like dennis robin just
go
missing yeah you can't find him and then
he's like oh there he is he showed up
i think it's west virginia that's gonna
go dennis robin man he's going full ride
yeah
honestly yeah yeah oh yeah i've always
said i don't know if i'd ever touch my
face with the tattoo but i'd definitely
go up my neck
definitely get up there but yeah get
that waylon jennings tattoo on your neck
dude
um awesome so on the way out today we're
going to check out their
their song let's do this man i was
thinking about this
let's think of different things before
you guys go um
and restless road is the ban yeah
let's think of things that k so kane i
was thinking like people nicknames
probably
people have for kane like i was thinking
like candy cane i'm sure your wife calls
you around christmas and stuff like that
so let's just go and we'll go in order
and see who can think of
a nickname for kane but it has to have
cane in it that's the thing it has to
have cane in it
cane yeah and if this doesn't work we
can take it out bro cuz we have editing
um
i got one because you know kane keynes
you know signed us and he got that that
kane brown money and he helps you know
pay for things for us so
yeah he just gave a thousand dollars to
some woman we met on television yeah
he's got that money
he's like he's our sugar cane sugarcane
there we go
boy that's good bro that's good um
maybe there could be a song called
purple cane by prince
cane i like that bro that's a good one
well we've always um i don't know why we
always have said this but when we're
going over to keynes it's always we
always reverse his name and say bane
crown
yes it kind of sounds like he's like
some villain in some like
his alternative like yeah superhero
movie he's bane crown baby
yeah it does bane crown sounds like a
like a villain in like a zaxby's
advertisement
yeah oh there's the evil chicken guy
bang crown
bane band crown okay kane's got one what
you got kane uh well i was in
elementary school and i had to go to the
bathroom
and uh i came i come out i left and i
come back and
all the kids were laughing i was like
what are y'all laughing and they were
like well
when you were leaving she was like she
yelled hurry came but it came out like
hurricane yeah i don't know
i think so yeah okay the storm hurricane
it's not that funny but
it was funny at the time very funny at
the time for second grade what
was it yeah yeah yeah it's like sake of
great humor you know what i mean oh
hugely good second grade i'm gonna go
with um
i'm gonna really take a detour here i'm
going to go with more of an appetizer
kane on the cob how about that
can we do that
i don't know if i like that one though
okay
that just sounds bad yeah might be bad
all right i got one for you in kane and
the membrane dude you got it
oh that's was that that was too small
too soon dude
[Laughter]
what about novocaine bro if you're
leaving the dentist what about novocaine
no kane no game no kane no game man
cocaine i used to be addicted to cocaine
but i'm sure that's
an easy one um
baked cane fried cane uh
what is it your rap name is two canes 2k
that's good
oh man i'm trying to think of it oh uh
um i'm still stuck on this candy cane
i've never heard
that in the beginning but now it's like
i wanna i almost want to cut
he would never let me call him that but
man that's for his wife
[Laughter]
maybe on christmas eve you could whisper
it to him but that's it bro
no um
can you see okay okay
what do you see what that woman
doing to me is that song
okay nobody liked it
there's the cane from the bible but i
think he either killed somebody or got
killed which one was it
he killed his brother yeah
well you know canaan the caney axe yeah
i could see that as like a group like a
the caniac the caniac oh country songs
are always talking about rain on an
old tin roof you could have a that's
like cane on an old tin roof
well we're going to cut that one out
that was horrible that was ours all
right
raising cane raising raisin cane is good
and i can't believe they haven't done a
collab you guys will at some point
you know maybe raising cane's chicken
yeah
i don't know they took my name though
stay in your cane
stay in your take a little trip down
memory king um
memory cane sugar cane did we do that
one yeah
sugar cane okay i think we you know we
did
look i'm just gonna let people know the
live show of them is gonna be way better
than the guessing
us guessing kane's nicknames
um i think that's probably good man yeah
yeah i think maybe on the way out we can
uh so tell us about this song that we're
gonna hear on the way out
yeah so uh we got this song out called
took one look at her mama
and it is um
it's awesome garrett can tell you a
little bit about kind of how it came
about
yeah um it was a couple years ago and uh
to preface this my dad is like my best
friend and he always has like
the best dad wisdom you know as dads do
but we're all sitting
at our apartment after cma fest about
four years ago
and i was dating this girl and uh we
were all sitting around and i asked my
dad and i said dad i really like this
girl but like how do i know if she's the
one
how can you be sure my dad just looked
over at me had like a mickelob ultra in
his hand and he said
son if you want to have some sort of
look into the future and know what a
life might be with this be like with
this girl he said all you got to do
is take one look at her mama and i was
like wow
that was crazy cool like he just said
that and so we
you know fast forward a few years later
we were trying to come up with a song
title and
zach had mentioned to me he was like
what about what your dad said like
took one look at her mama like you know
that would be a great song title so we
all sat down
over the quarantine and uh we we whipped
it up and uh yeah now it's our
next single so it's just crazy how that
happens
that's dope man yeah that's that's
important
well congratulations guys and uh and
congratulations to you kane on on being
able to circle back up with these guys
and all you guys really coming full
circle man that's beautiful it's cool
when things like that happen
in life you know yeah man thank you um
and i guess
we'll just we can go out on that man is
that cool with you yeah we'll go out
on that on on restless road the song is
called
took one look at her mama took one look
at her mama
[Music]
yep
she got a heart of gold
she lights up every room she walks in
[Music]
i was just sitting here
but there's no better time than like a
career that's rising yeah
[Music]
yeah restless road man thank you guys so
much
man
absolutely we'd love that gang man you
guys take care see y'all boys
[Music]
as soon as i saw it my baby done got
that smile